-Guys, today is Friday,
and that's usually when
I catch up on
some personal stuff.
I check my in-box,
I return some e-mails,
and, of course,
I send out thank-you notes.
And I was running
a bit behind, so I thought --
Yeah, thank you, sir or ma'am.
If you guys wouldn't mind,
can I write out some
thank-you notes right now?
[ Cheers and applause ]
I appreciate that.
James, can I get some
thank-you-note-writing music,
please?
[ Soft music playing ]
Wow.
-Wow!
-Looks like he's in a good mood.
-Yeah.
-He's in a good mood tonight.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, this week, for giving
us 70-degree weather one day,
30 degrees the next,
and blacking out at 5:00 p.m.
Mother nature, you're drunk.
Go to bed.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go off.
Come on.
-Alright.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, wool scarves,
for giving everyone
resting itch face.
-Nice!
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you,
Space Force uniforms,
for making service members
look very prepared to protect
an FAO Schwarz.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
Poor Space Forcers.
-Well, there's no
Space Force veterans.
-Yeah, no. Exactly.
-So we can --
-Come on.
-Yeah, we're gonna --
-They're called space cadets!
-Yes.
-Thank you.
Space cadets.
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you, standing desks,
for being a great way to
stay fit at work
for three weeks until you go,
"Hey, does anyone
want this standing desk?
I'm not gonna do this.
Back is killing me."
-And a ball?
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you, salad tongs,
for looking like
a spoon, a fork, and a pair of
scissors are in a throuple.
-Throuple.
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you,
Captain America Chris Evans,
for being named
"People's" Sexiest Man Alive.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm happy for you, but come on,
you're not even the best-looking
captain in this room.
Come on!
That's what I'm talking about.
There you have it.
Those were my thank-you notes.
We'll be right back with
"Freestylin' with The Roots,"
everybody. Come on.